welcome back to the morning toast we are
very excited and honored to be sitting
down with dr. deborah birx a physician
and diplomat who serves as a response
coordinator for the White House
coronavirus task force she is a longtime
health official who spent nine years on
the government's point person on global
efforts to fight HIV and AIDS at the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention toasters probably recognize
her and her fabulous collection of
scarves from the daily White House press
conferences dr. Burks thank you so much
for being here glad to be here you are
working tirelessly you are looking
fabulous while doing it fabulous we
appreciate both elements equally a
medical icon and a fashion icon love to
see it
my daughter's wouldn't agree with you
but thank you we know your time is
valuable and we don't want to waste any
of it we got so many questions for you I
think that largely due to the fact that
there's so much misinformation being
spread out there and a lot of people are
like nervous to ask questions so when
they knew you were coming on you are the
expert you are the go-to person for
questions they were so excited to to ask
I think most of our audience being young
Millennials are social distancing but
there's a lot of confusion as to what
social distancing actually is can you
give us the explanation official from
the White House
so social distancing means that you
cannot at anytime point be closer than
six feet to any person for more than 10
minutes so yeah I know
so you're not exactly social distanced
so this is really quite important
because that and it's all scientifically
based on how respiratory diseases are
transmitted and transmitted from your
mouth or your nose to someone else and
we got a lot of questions about it
potentially being transmitted through
surfaces so if if you touch something
that someone else touched can you get
the virus through that way as well so
that is the really concerning part
because we touch a lot of stuff and we
don't think about it and so really
ensuring hand-washing is important but
it's not going to be enough in this case
you got to be aware of every time you've
touched a surface particularly a hard
surface so we don't think fat
bricks are as critical in transmission
as hard surfaces so if you've touched
any hard surface you need to wash your
hands or you mean to make sure your
hands are away from your face until you
can get your hands washed
yes that's what we've been practicing
it's hard not to touch your face dr.
Burks it's really high it exactly
because we're used to we're used to the
hair thing
so we yeah even moving your hair around
you will rush your face and that will
put the virus on your face and then it's
very close to your eyes and your nose
and your mouth where it's transmitted
yes can the virus be transmitted through
the air for example if I'm walking down
the street to get only the necessities
and someone walks past me and they
coughed and I walk through their coughs
could I get it so these are the really
that's a really critical question and I
think no one knows the actual answer to
that so I want to be clear if I said
never people would find the one case we
do know with another corona virus called
SARS the original one from 2003 there
was one time that they thought it was
transmitted through the ventilation
system but that's forced air and so you
know if you walk past if you're 6 feet
apart
their cough cannot reach you but it
means that you always have to be aware
of exactly where you are and where other
people are and there there's so many
rumors about corona virus and one of
them a lot of people are spreading and I
don't even know if there's any proof
behind it is that hopefully when the
warmer weather comes the virus won't be
able to live in warm weather and will
therefore die off is that true or even
remotely possible any evidence to
suggest that so if you look through
North America respiratory diseases and
you look at our normal diseases that
occur in the winter months from flu to
the actual original SARS outbreak that
occurred in the winter months two other
viruses that we know occur in winter
months there's summer viruses and
there's winter viruses winter viruses
normally come up in November peak
somewhere around December January
beginning of February and come back down
so we're actually move
out of flu season right now and so
there's a lot of people who have any
look at the original SARS data get
excited that it could have a seasonality
just like SARS and just like flu because
we've never seen this virus before we
can't definitively say that we think
part of the reason viruses like this are
less in the summer is because we
naturally social distance more and we're
not all closed up in the same household
right that's very true a lot of our
listeners re their new moms young moms
expecting moms have we seen anything
about corona virus in pregnancy or even
giving birth in the hospitals situation
what couldn't pregnant women expect
expect you know that's a really
important question because my daughter
has two children um one is about 27
months and one is only about ten months
I haven't seen them in the last three
graduates congratulations and their
videos but I think this is really a very
important because every pregnant woman
is so concerned about their baby and so
there were only nine cases reported out
of China we're trying to get more data
what I can tell in that very limited set
and a couple different pregnancies and
deliveries that have happened since is
both mommies and babies are doing
terrifically and the mortality data
still shows really only three total
cases from around the world of
individuals under 20 succumbing to this
disease so I think and we don't know if
they had pre-existing conditions so to
every pregnant mom practice the same
level of social distancing what might be
really great as you won't get all those
colds because now you know you can't
take medication and you're always
getting a cold when you're pregnant is
horrible so this may help keep all of
that down so when it comes to
Millennials who are quarantine alot of
people are wondering if you're starting
to show symptoms is it best to continue
to quarantine yourself and just medicate
and get better or are you supposed to go
out and get tested and risking opening
yourself up to other infections and
contaminating other
people so if you're a young person ie a
millennial really you should stay home
and call your physician or call your mom
or call whoever you're normally in
contact with about health issues there's
new options now differ actually your
physician to be able to just talk you
through called telehealth so you can get
information of course a lot of the
information is on the CDC website I
think the most important thing is to
stay home and try not to infect the
others in your household so that so your
quarantine in your household and now
we're asking you to quarantine into a
room very separate yeah so double
quarantine well for people who are
experiencing symptoms what are some
medications that they can take that
might help believe those symptoms so
your normal over-the-counter cold
medication I just want to put a caution
out for that because I obviously my two
daughters and they're my two son in-laws
are all Millennials they have a habit of
mixing medication so me the back of the
box and if it has tylenol any kind of
acetaminophen product that's the only
one that you really need to be careful
with you don't want to take really more
than 2,000 or 3,000 milligrams a day of
that so when you're double medicating
because you're taking like a dayquil
like substance and then you think oh I
have a fever I'm gonna take tylenol
don't do that because the de aquila
nyquil already have tylenol in it and so
if someone gets infected from
coronavirus and gets better is it
possible for them to get reinfected you
know it's a great question and again we
never say never because you know you'll
find the one case in a million but so
far we believe just like with any other
virus you develop an antibody response
to that virus as well as what we call
cellular immunity that's your t-cells so
you have B cells that make antibodies
t-cells that make are naturally
antivirals they're your first line of
defense after your skin these natural
killer cells and T cells and then you
make antibody and that's the long-lived
substance that's your memory substance
and there's no reason to think that you
would get reinfected with this exact
coronavirus one that's a little bit
different potentially but not this one
okay and so I think a lot of people are
wondering like for the most part most
people are abiding by the rules they're
staying in their house in an attempt to
flatten the curve and for us it's been
almost nine days on day 11 so we're
curious
hey is it working is it working are we -
lately flattening the curve so okay now
this is this is a really important
question because what we're seeing today
are things that evolved over the last
two to three weeks so the people who are
coming to the hospital today remember it
takes between two and 14 days to get
infected it may take another five or six
days to develop symptoms so now it takes
a week to 20 days to get really sick and
then it takes another three or four days
potentially to be hospitalized and
another few days in the hospital and
that's all cascading we mostly see the
sick people we don't see the individuals
with the mild symptoms so it's very
difficult within two weeks alone to see
the full breadth of what we're doing and
how we're stopping infections we're
watching it early very closely because
March 8th they really did what we are
doing now and so really seeing how
Italy's numbers look I think will inform
us a lot because they're a week ahead of
us and then we'll have a real sense I
think the president is very interested
in figuring out what do we say after the
two weeks the 15 days or stopping the
spread and we're looking at that every
single day from a data standpoint and
we'll evaluate then we also have a lot
of listeners who work in the health
field their nurses their doctors their
pas and a lot of them had a lot of
questions about the shortage of personal
protective equipment and what kind of
plan is in place to help them get those
types of supplies because they're
struggling right now yeah so we're
really trying to align the need with the
supply and you know how it is when
you've gone to the store and the three
people ahead of you bought all the
toilet paper there was that half
between hospitals and hospital systems
and clinics and so we're really trying
to find out where everything is can that
be moved around while we also release
significant amounts from the stockpile
and that's millions of mass coming out
of the stockpile and going into
communities that really need it and
another question we got for you is from
people who might be a little confused
about the symptoms because a lot of
people are now having seasonal allergies
and maybe being paranoid that they might
have coronavirus so what are the
official coronavirus symptoms
okay so allergies your right can look
particularly in mild cases of
coronavirus can look very similar but
you shouldn't get a fever with your
allergies you can get a fever with your
allergies if you get sinusitis but I
think we all know what that looks like
and how that feels and that's really
pressure in the front of your face so if
you're just having a runny nose and a
scratchy throat and no fever that's
probably your allergies if you have a
history of allergies now if you don't
have a history of allergies they don't
although they do come on this is not the
season well they never appear out of
nowhere so I always get nervous when
people are sick and they tell me it's
their allergies so let's all agree
together that we're gonna be honest
about when we really know that we have a
cold and not say that it's allergies and
if you have a cold because many
Millennials it may feel like a cold it
may feel like the flu if it's either of
those things it's really important that
you stay home and then one last thing
we're finding new data out of China and
around the world that some of the early
symptoms may be GI so that's another
piece of all of this that you may have
early GI kind of sensitive guests or
intestinal symptoms that then evolved
into cold like symptoms got it yeah so
coronavirus is a hypochondriac worst
nightmare yes well could say yes and
that's why it's really important that
you all support one another and I think
that's so critical for you all to say
yes no I feel like that too
that's my allergy so it's reassuring to
each other and then really
staying in contact with each other
reminding people to take their
temperature yeah and people are really I
think desperate to help and I know that
staying home is one of the biggest ways
you can be helpful but as a young
healthy person is there something else
we could be doing I think there's a lot
you can be doing one you are amazing
about creating social dynamics in a
virtual way for communities and I think
I'm really relying on you all to keep
communities integrated and speaking to
one another and feeling like they're
still part of a community because the
better a community is about self
isolating the better the results will be
for that community so I think figuring
out how you stay in touch yet be distant
and I think I know you can all figure
that out and then really how to keep
informing your parents about some of the
not-so-smart things they're doing
because yeah they're not always doing
what they're supposed to be doing
wait well there are a lot of people out
there and even celebrities who feel like
the response doesn't match like the
level of sick people or the amount of
deaths what would you say to those
people who don't understand why we're
taking such extreme action they think
we're overreacting yeah so I think this
is really important because remember
we're by the time you see death you
really let the virus get out of control
because I explained it took two to three
weeks to get to that it's a highly
contagious virus and so you can see what
happened in Italy they waited until they
were seeing a lot of people die in the
older age groups and then realized that
they had such a significant problem
and you can go from thinking you've got
this to where there's thousands of
people in the hospital that are not
being adequately cared for so that's
what we're trying to prevent across
America by taking this early responsive
comprehensive approach to really I know
it sounds theoretical flattening the
curve but it is the difference between
your grandmother and grandfather
surviving or not surviving right well is
there any positive news that you can
share with us you know something that
might be optimistic or hopeful something
we're doing right or any good news were
see
deaths I'm really impressed at how
people have adapted to these guidelines
and really ensure that they're following
them I'm also really impressed about how
well people have worked between the
Republican and Democratic Party and how
well them to say that sector has stood
up and said let us help I can tell you I
probably get a hundred emails a day from
different private sector entities saying
how can I help what can I do I have this
or I have the construction company when
we were able to figure out that the
construction masts were identical to the
hospital masts one was green and one was
tan but they were identical and how they
work the construction industry found
hundreds of thousands of these masks and
donated them to hospitals that's what's
happening and that level of generosity
stores creating senior times for
shopping all of this kind of innovation
it gives me incredible hope that there's
a lot more innovation I mean what will
get us through this is our innovation
plus our dedication to each other so
true well you are out here doing the
Lord's work we really really appreciate
everything you're doing I'm sure you're
not sleeping you haven't seen your
family but it's all for the greater good
and before we let you're so thankful we
have one final question oh yeah
because inevitably Hollywood is going to
make a movie about this pandemic who
would you want to play you we have some
ideas Julia Roberts oh yeah we were
thinking maybe Charlize Theron I was
thinking maybe Renee Zellweger hang on
could yeah way young well dr. Burks it
has really been an honor to get to speak
with you thank you for taking the time
and thank you for all the hard work you
and the entire task force are doing we
really appreciate it and thank you to
the toasters for listening we hope you
have a great day guys we'll see you
tomorrow thank you thank you for your
work